of all the things that unite americans
nothing compares to sports
sports are how we mark the changing of
the seasons sports draw us to the sounds
of rubber on the court in the spring the
greenest fields you've ever seen in the
summer the crisp fall days of tailgates
and college chants the cold snow games
of winter where you can't feel your toes
but you won't sit down it is a
connection to the past and the future
generations of fans from all backgrounds
all walks of life who find themselves
together to share in sorrow or glory as
the day decides
sports is our great teacher offering us
lessons that guide us from a young age
for the rest of our lives lessons about
courage and grit the importance of
teamwork and diligence how to play like
a champion even in a loss
sports has been at the center of
american understanding about race
immigration religion and meritocracy the
baseball playoffs begin tonight and from
jackie robinson to sandy kofax to
roberto clemente our children learned
what it means to be a good american from
watching these larger-than-life figures
give their all in the field of play
so why is it that sports today seems to
be a place of division not unity
something used to break us further apart
not bring us together
when did competition become such a bad
thing
20 years ago after 9 11 getting back to
sports was incredibly important it
wasn't just a sign that america was
going to continue it was a sign that we
were confident and unafraid
eight years ago tears turned to cheers
and roars when david ortiz told those
cowardly marathon terrorists just whose
city boston was
the same motivation exists today as we
were first coming back from lockdowns we
all joined the crowds of fans whose
proud voices carried our national anthem
but this creates an extreme division
between what we are told and what we see
on the screen
you probably heard on sunday dr anthony
fauci talking about whether we can have
christmas gatherings or not well he did
that on cbs
between this
and this
as much as media fear mongers decry
these college and pro football games as
super spreader events the evidence shows
they don't have a leg to stand on
in recent weeks the use of sports divide
us has moved to individual players and
their personal beliefs about vaccination
nba players like jonathan isaac and
draymond green have mounted eloquent
defenses on the right to make their own
medical decisions making it clear that
yes they've thought this through much to
the frustration of the overwhelmingly
leftist sports journalists who want them
to go along with the narrative
and let's talk about those journalists
particularly espn the worldwide leader
has been a constant force for division
in recent years driving race and gender
focused narratives lauding acts of
leftist political protest and even
sidelining qualified reporters like
rachel nichols in service of the woke
agenda just today the excellent and
talented sage steele is facing enormous
backlash for her comments on race
vaccine mandates and more
failed former espn host turned colin
kaepernick biopic producer jamel hill
called her a clown for expressing those
views espn says they embrace different
points of view in a statement but do
they really this would be a good test
let's consider someone who espn has had
on their programming for years
journalism professor kevin blackstone of
maryland what are some of his views well
he's repeatedly called for boycotting
israel from all sports and even banning
them from the olympics as an apartheid
state he's called for pulling the
all-star game from atlanta and denying
future sports events to georgia over
their election integrity law and he
called for banning military flyovers and
the playing of the national anthem which
he calls a war anthem before games even
complained about being forced to sit
through it
that's a leftist academic whose opinion
espn thinks you need to hear that's not
a problem like when sage steel shares
her opinions she broke rule number one
she talked and she said something low
corporate didn't agree with
americans are tired of this woke crap
particularly when it's filled with the
underlying hypocrisy of cow towing to
the interests of china by now you know
all about that story how an american
sports league with a corrupt
relationship with shoemakers made in
horrible overseas conditions had to
engage in all manner of song and dance
pretending to look the other way because
the gm had the audacity to send one
tweet
lebron james has lots of opinions but
china what does he know about china
as author ethan strauss long-time nba
reporter writes it could be argued that
the nba fixates more on china than on
america even if the vast majority of tv
money comes from the u.s viewership the
league figures it has more or less hit
its ceiling in its home country so china
becomes an obsession as this massive
theoretical growth engine
this isn't a question about republicans
or democrats at some point you have to
ask
do they hate their customers for being
american
is what's really going on here wishful
thinking desiring to dissolve that fan
base that wants beer and trucks and
action movies and instead aspire for a
fan base where the wnba outsells michael
jordan's newly toxic masculinity
as with so many other areas of american
life the institution of sports is being
turned against the very people who go to
the games and buy the tickets and cheer
it is driven both by globalist
corporations who no longer think of
themselves as innately american and by a
leftist dominated media complex who
despises the fans of the very games they
cover closer to home parents must worry
about their daughters competing against
their neighbor's sons because of
intersectional madness masquerading as
tolerance even proudly lesbian athletes
like tennis champion martinez
navratilova have expressed concerns
about the challenges posed by allowing
trans girls to complete a compete
against biological girls
but despite all this
sports finds a way
there is still that human desire for the
connection that brings us together as
fans despite all the efforts to divide
us
my mom is a dedicated baseball fan here
she is with her friends scooter and
bobby for years they've sat together and
shared stories and gripes and cheered on
the nationals throughout the season they
have strong opinions about everything in
dc sports for the past 50 years
there is no reason that people from such
different walks of life should end up as
friends but that's the power of sports
it brings us together in ways that
surprise us it gives us ideals to strive
for and even as the left has sought to
corrupt sports with their woke agenda
their mission is ultimately doomed they
view sports as a tool to use against the
people when we know it binds us together
as citizens and friends
dr fouch you can't stand in front of a
hundred thousand joyous screaming penn
state fans
i'd like to see him try
i'm ben dominic and this is the american
crisis hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else